business owners in miami beach say they
are shouldering the economic burden of
these curfews as businesses on the west
coast say they're being punished because
of coveted restrictions
here to talk about both of these
challenges is ray schnitzer
owner of the 11th street diner in miami
beach in barrett lapajian
owner of the tin horn flat saloon and
grill in burbank california gentlemen
welcome
thank you thanks for having us ray first
you had to stay in business during a
pandemic now rowdy spring breakers in
miami beach what has been the impact of
all
of that on your business well it's been
tough
because number one back in june when we
opened we had to follow all the cdc
guidelines and protocols so that we
could open which is very costly
so that we could open with regard to
uh following those guidelines now
one of which was 50 inside dining which
was okay we could make ends meet with
inside donnie with a supplement of
outside seating
but as time progressed this the whole
thing about
spring break is it's it's a misnomer
number one
the spring break now this has all this
started way back when
years and years ago when it was kind of
branded
memorial weekend branded as uh urban
weekend so that carryover came all the
way into
uh into the beginning when when desantis
let us open up at the end of may
beginning of june
and with the stimulus money in
particular and cheap air flights and
cheap hotel rooms slash
airbnb we got an influx of predominantly
city people so
majority of which were are great just
the young kids you know they always like
to push the envelope and push as far as
they can
but as far as the impact now because the
curfew
what what should happen begin in the
beginning is the city dropped the ball i
won't even get into all that
uh as far as policing goes but now
thus the mayor in the city of miami
beach with the mandate
for this new curfew because we got
yoyoed all the way from june
until now until now from a curfew from
eight
until 10 until midnight and and now
going from midnight
back to eight we where you have to close
at seven it's
truly impacted our business as far as
revenue goes because during the day
60 of our revenue is probably the our
morning shift and 40
at night and within that 40 percent now
we've been dropped down to probably 20
of that 40 so it's it's a big it's a big
hit
but more importantly on top and on top
of that let me bring embarrassment one
of the guests
sorry let me bring in our other guest
barrett you've had challenges of your
own
obviously covered but also governor
gavin newsom declaring restaurants
closed
tell us about your story uh
mike um you know we were going going
along uh last year
uh complying with what they were saying
and uh towards the end of last year
about december you know
they just closed everything back down
again you know indoors
outdoors and there was no explanations
there was no reason
it just you know and that's after us
doing all the things we have to do
you know plastic coverings and
everything and after about three or four
days
you know with with uh no reason behind
it i just opened up
simply opened up i was going to lose my
business anyway you know i mean uh
they kept it closed now two months
completely closed down
and and so right now i'm i'm running
without power and i'm running without uh
phone lines the city has you know they
tried uh
uh padlocking our doors which you know
we
we unpad lock them and you know our
supporters have been
beyond tremendous and we're we're we're
working
we're we are in business but it's
obviously quite challenging with the
extra restrictions right
really difficult you know my son and my
daughter
really run the day-to-day operations of
it and
i mean you know you can only imagine how
stressful it is i mean we have backup
generators that are
uh supporters have helped us uh you know
have provided us i mean they've actually
did the electrical work
and everything but trying to run a
restaurant is complicated and stressful
enough
but without without power and without
it's a mess i can honestly tell you that
well barrett
ray thank you so much for your time we
wish you and your employees the very
best
hang in there thank you sir thank you
very much